[Music]
speaking of the royal baby i really
loved uh that the baby's birth was
announced by a town crier
yeah do you believe that a town crisis a
town crier it's an old tradition a town
crier well actually we have our own town
crier who makes important announcements
in our studio
and he's here now and he's not just a
town crier
he's a john crier
[Applause]
oh yay oh yay oh yay
let it be known
that conan o'brien pays celebrities for
their cameo appearances
not with money
but with half empty boxes of donuts
stolen from the craft service table at
the
[Applause]
oh
mentalist
oh yay oh yay
let it be known
that someone in this studio has not been
paying attention to the show
and just moments ago was using his
mobile phone to checkyelp.com for patio
furniture suppliers
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yay oh yay
i have yet
another important announcement regarding
your cameraman
costa
he will need to leave early this evening
okay well that's that's fine
for a doctor's appointment okay that's
that's fine thank you
to treat a painful inflammation in a
rather sensitive area
that area is located all right i think
that's that's enough thank you thank
oh
you
oh yay
oh yay
what what what is it what
can i keep this hat
no
oh come on i mean i i just i'll borrow
it for the weekend i i i have a funeral
yes okay you can have it for the two yes
[Applause]